HIS SECOND TONIGHT.UL
REALLY EASY FOR NIKOLA JOKIC.
ANY OTHER HUMANANHAT.
WHAT CAN DOE
IT'S OVER THE HIM LATE.
CROSS OFF, SO
PLAYERS ARE RUNNING ON THE
COURT. ERS FOR THREE!
YES!
DEFENDER THAN YOU REALIZE.
HOW ABOUT THE WAY HE SHOT THE
BALL
THE SOMBOR SHUFFLE JUST THEM TH
THIRD FOUL ON HOWARD.
THERE IS THAT MAY TAG
OVER IN THAT DEAL LASTFORWARD.
>> Mark: TIPPED OUT OF BOUNDS.
WI GOOD FOROR
HE JUST A SIXTH
ALL-STAR TEAM AS A GIANNIS  JOB.
TRIES TO GIVE IT TO O'NEALE.
18.
JOKIC ON THE  WATCH JOKER, HE G
TO THE BASKET.
HE THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO GET
THAT PUSH.
I THINK IT WASTRYING TO DO SOME.
AGAIN --
>> Mark: HERE IT
JOKIC ON THE MOVE.
THE GUY HAS GIDDEY ON HIS BACK
AND STANDING RIGHT HERE.
DOWN TOSCREEN, THEY SWITCH
IT.
YOU GOT BOL THROUGH. THAT PRESS
1:35 TO GO. THAT'S
BARTON PLAYING WITH HIS FOOD UP
TOP.
BEBEMBMBRYRY H HASAS J JOKOKICI,
STSTUTUTTETER,R, ONE FOR THE
TRIPLE-DN ANOTHER
REBOUND.
SNAP A PASS TO JOKIC WHO
GREEN.
ARE YOU SHOOT.
DUMP IT THREE GUYS ON
JOJOKIKIC,C, G GREREATAT F FEEE.
GIVE IT TO GORDON W W
THEY ARE YOU ARE GIVING THE BAL
AWAY AT ONE END.